[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien vous dire comme c'est des génies en
régime cheryl on monte un peu la brousse
ils ont coupé aux deux mêmes sont ni
temps d'enlever de trois extraits on va
se faire plaisir surtout avec tout ce
qui va être drôle dans la bande-annonce
[Rires]
impôts est bon et il faut pareil dans
l'émission mais c'est pour ça qu'on les
ait ben voilà patrick voulait dire un
petit mot la régie d'audit désigneront
merci c'est gentil on va repasser la
bande annonce à la fin de l'émission la
vraie la vraie et vous verrez les cette
différence voilà plus est ce qu'ils ont
enlevé dans la bande annonce valérie or
on s'est régalé